michael bidwell cardinals chairman
earlier this week appearing on 98.7 fm
in phoenix was discussing the issue of
a 17th game which really does feel
inevitable we'll get to that coming up
but he said this about 17 games i think
our fans would like more we have
surveyed our fans
we have surveyed our fans that's an
important point to remember the health
and safety data plays out that we can do
17 games and it's not going to impact
the safety and health of the players now
i i got curious when i saw that shireen
because and and if we hadn't had a poll
last week on pft's twitter account it
may have just gone over my head i may
have thought hey they've surveyed their
fans and the fans want it yeah why
wouldn't they want it they want more
everybody wants more
but the poll we did last week and this
was by no means a push poll this wasn't
aimed at trying to get anyone to pick
any specific outcome do you want a 17
game regular season
yes 38
no 62 percent
plus
uh and i was stunned by the outcome i
was stunned by it because i just assume
people want it and i wouldn't have
thought anything about this survey that
was mentioned by michael bidwell if we
hadn't done our own twitter poll and 56
000 plus that that's a pretty good
sample size and one thing we've learned
over the years of doing these polls the
the trends that pop up in the first 500
to 1 000 those numbers they pretty much
stay the same no matter how many people
end up responding to the poll question
so sharing what i did was i asked the
cardinals and i asked the league
what's the
the cert give me some details about the
survey i'm curious about this what were
the questions how many people responded
and uh both the league and the cardinals
acknowledged that it was anecdotal
feedback that there really hasn't been a
survey and that kind of surprises me for
something this big
right
for for an expansion of the regular
season
i guess they just assume maybe you don't
need to do a survey maybe you don't need
to do a poll maybe you just assume
people are going to consume it we're
going to give you more football and what
are you going to do not watch it of
course you're going to watch it another
game involving your favorite team
another opportunity to to play fantasy
football another opportunity to gamble
yeah you're not going to say no to it so
i was just kind of surprised that
they're citing a survey that they never
did and you take a step back
and the reality is you don't need to do
a survey people will consume an extra
week of football
mike i voted in that poll and i voted no
i don't want to see another week just
think about this we got president's day
coming up on monday
we'd be getting ready for the super bowl
right now we'd be in miami or wherever
the super bowl site was this week do you
want the season to go that long i have
never heard any fan and i am around fans
a lot i have never heard a fan say i
want more games i want to see more
football i am shocked that they haven't
done some surveys i want to see player
survey do you want the 17th game and i
think we all know how that survey is
going to come out i want to hear coaches
surveyed because you know what you're
taking away you're going to take away
more of their off season program by
extending the season out they're going
to lose some of that and we know coaches
don't like losing practice time which
they're going to do and i want to see
fans survey do you want the 17th game
think about the 17th week the 16th game
that we have now
this past season we had some really dog
games a lot of dog games more dog games
than we had games that mattered we all
think about that tennessee game but
there were some really bad games
that last week meaningless games coaches
don't like to use that word but that's
absolutely what they were they turned it
they turned that last week into the
preseason so now we have those last two
weeks as preseason type games i just i
don't like it and i don't know many fans
who like have you have you ever heard a
fan say i want more nfl football
no no they don't but but the reality is
if they get more nfl football they're
not going to say no to it especially as
legalized gambling continues to spread
people want things that they can bet on
and as it relates to health and safety
shireen the nfl later pointed out to me
that back in november
dr john york the chairman of the 49ers
explained to the athletic that they've
determined that reducing the preseason
by one game and increasing the regular
season by a game will balance out any
potential impact on health and safety
but here's the reality if you expand the
regular season in 17 games
the starters are playing 17 games and
the starters aren't playing pre-season
games as it is they barely make a cameo
appearance now and it will be even less
if they've got 17 regular season games
to try to survive through so i think
that that we all get it as to what's
going to happen here the players who are
good enough to play all the time are
going to play an extra game and of
course they're going to have their
health and safety impacted you're adding
an extra game to their workload
well mike you're asking the question too
about
yeah they're going to watch it what's
the saturation point for this league is
there a saturation point because we know
if they go to 17 they're going to 18. is
there a saturation point for this lake
i think the saturation point is 20 and i
hope they don't get to 20 in my lifetime
although maybe i maybe i i should say i
hope they do because i think eventually
it will be 20 and maybe there'll be no
preseason at all right hey we played 20
games anyway we don't need the preseason
these guys are in shape all year long
let's throw them out there and make
every game count i mean that's really
what this comes down to they want more
games that count because as more and
more states have legalized betting there
will be more and i mean we're talking
about billions more in revenue for the
nfl that's what this is about and it
doesn't matter whether we want it it
doesn't matter whether the fans want it
it doesn't matter whether the players
want it
they want it
they run the league
and it's coming
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports